why doesn't hisoka want to fight
karapika it's not a simple question to
answer because hisoka is not a simple
man he's a very complex series of
rubbery gummy whims constantly
intersecting and getting stuck to one
another and just confusing the whole
situation for everyone involved there is
a logic to it though and everything
stems from the very first Arc during the
hunter exam hisoka was an applicant
however he had far less interest in
passing the exam than he did in
administering his own exam hisoka was
using a lot of his time to find how
shall we put this potential Playmate I
used that term because hisoka tends to
describe the people he's interested in
as toys but since nothing in this exam
could threaten him hisoka chose to use
his time more efficiently hisoka's quest
to find someone to satisfy his battle
boner is most prominent in the Milky
Wetlands which was part two of the first
phase of the hunter exam although it was
more like the fifth trial in total at
that point I don't know that a lot of
things happened during this phase hisoka
encountered a group of three people whom
he decided to test this group consisted
of karapika Leorio and dap but you good
old you candidate number 76 whose name
is allegedly cherry and yes good old
Cherry sure he'll be important to the
future of the series The One generic
character design standing next to two
very clear main characters now he
doesn't exist to die at all in any case
hisoka's test is as follows he walks
towards them intimidatingly and the test
is to judge what they do in response at
which point krapika and Cherry choose to
run however leori decides to stay even
knowing that he has no real chance of
beating hisoka furthermore a wild gone
also appears as a surprise candidate to
assist leoria leorium gets whacked in
the face and gone is treated to the
close-up smile of a child groomer
however hisoka says that both of them
have passed the test he even picks up
Leorio and Carries him to the end of the
phase but whilst both Leorio and gone
past hisoka's exam karapika failed the
exam because hisoka wasn't looking for
people who constantly run away from him
he already had that sort of relationship
happening with crawler no hisoko is
looking for people who excite him to be
will willing to indulge his battle
Clowny whims and I guess you could think
of it as a sort of Twisted speed dating
hisoka was looking for someone to
actually engage with him as opposed to
karapika who in this metaphor just looks
disinterested for the entire date and
swiftly moves on as soon as he possibly
can cherry also failed this exam and so
hisoka went on to brutally murder him
for the lulls afterwards but it's not so
much that hisoka wasn't interested in
karapika it's more that he knew the
krapika wasn't interested in him let me
explain via gone after this experience
gone recalled the Tariff hisoka and said
well it's weird but it felt pretty
exciting too ding ding ding that that is
a match that is exactly what hisoka
wants someone who also understands the
thrill of deadly deadly combat which is
why gone becomes the obsession from here
on out krapika doesn't understand that
and hisoka may be many things but
consensual combat is important to him
and right now the only two candidates
for that are gone and leoria however
that did shift a bit during hisoka's
interview with nettera when netaro asked
which candidates hisoka finds most
interesting his response is 405 and 99
AKA gone and kilowatt but he also
replies that he doesn't want to fight
either of them just now assumedly
because they need time to grow like the
juicy battle fruit that hisoka sees them
as the karapika isn't even in this
conversation at this stage he's a bronze
medal maybe even lower because ilami was
also participating in the exam who would
have caught hisoka's interest and at
this point even leoria was showing more
of what hisoku was looking for if
everyone here kropica is like a 5 out of
10. acceptable in a desperate situation
I suppose but not something that you go
out of your way to pursue however this
did not stop hisoka using karapika
hisoka and karapika did briefly fight
during the final stage although hisoka
quickly put a stop to that with his
special whisper drawn here by Togashi in
a panel that makes it look like they're
about to kiss and is even more
lipscombly charged in a later flashback
where Togashi really puts an emphasis on
those their lips hisoka basically said I
know a thing about the spiders so meet
me at this time at this place you said
me maybe in York New City on September
1st that is both time and a place it's a
big city though but then he resigned
essentially being the one to give
karapika his hunter license so krapika
may have failed hisokus test but at the
very least he passed another however
there may still be some interest here
when the meeting time finally comes a
sensation he soakers are familiar with
he states don't worry I don't intend to
fight you now which is one of the very
few pieces of evidence that shows that
hisoka has any interest in karapika at
all but in this world of gonze killers
illamies and crawlils karapika just
isn't worth the investment right now and
potentially won't ever be worth it ever
which I find fascinating because of
everyone in this series krapika is the
one who I would say is closest to crolo
in almost every regard obviously this
wasn't a factor during the hunter exam
due to a lack of nen and experience but
karapika's true potential would become
apparent during York new the key thing
here though is that hisoka is using
krapika to get closer to crawler
hisoka's primary issue is going back to
the dating metaphor the crolo is always
surrounded by his friends there's never
an opportunity to approach crolo alone
and try to lay on some of the classic
battle clown charm so he wants to use
karapika to draw crawler's friends away
in essence kropica during the sock
becomes hisoka's wingman and he even
makes this quite clear to krapika by
saying it's not like we're getting
married just some give and take which is
hisoka laying down the boundaries of
this relationship look karapika nothing
is going to happen between us we're just
friends in fact yeah hisoka is basically
friend zone in karapika here however at
the end of York New City heartbreak
occurs as hisoka's wingman ends up doing
the exact opposite and blocks
hisoka by taking away crolo's ability to
use nen and you know I think this says a
lot about kropica's battle dating
potential he mostly on his own mind you
outsmarted and outplayed the Phantom
truth this is very crowler-like behavior
and yet hisoka still has no interest
what happens is that hisoka spends his
time pining over the loss of beloved to
crolo even going so far as to enter
Greed Island to find a nen Exorcist to
rectify the whole situation now to be
completely Fair here at the time this
occurred kropica would have been off
limits regardless hisoka knows that
crolo has been cursed and so the one
person hisoka cannot engage is karapika
because killing him as fun and maybe
sensually satisfying as it could be
would only make his goal of fighting
crawler an impossibility The Troop
themselves gave up on trying to kill
karapika because they assumed that the
potential post-mortem nen would only
intensify the curse but every bit of
behavior up until this point shows he
soak his feelings towards krapika a very
battle platonic he respects karapika but
there's no real desire to take that next
step and why is that because I
personally don't see what hisoka loves
so much about crolo that he doesn't also
see in krapika the two of them both like
to play hard to get garoppica
demonstrating this when he ran during
the hunter exam meanwhile crawler
constantly vanishes from hisoka and even
ran for a whole year straight after
having his curse lifted they're both
very no-nonsense extremely intelligent
and wildly versatile nen users in fact
at this point krapika can also steal
abilities so there's always an element
of surprise much like with crawler the
only real difference at this stage is
that crolo is much more mature than
karapika he has juicy battle fruit ripe
for the picking acropica also has that
potential and yet there's never any gone
style Schwing in that general direction
so perhaps hisoka just isn't interested
in blondes or maybe he's much more
combat monogamous than we've been led to
believe except that that's not true at
all because the chairman election Arc
showed us more so than any other that
hisoka is a combat polygamist hisoka
showed up to the election like a tourist
in Amsterdam visiting the red light
district he was there to assess
candidates for his own personal pleasure
sifting through a rather disappointing
sea of hunters all worth less than 50
points with some of the zodiacs catching
his eye but in the end Far and Away the
most exciting candidate was illumi with
a score of 95. and you know during the
succession War it's also been made clear
that hisoka and illumi have a bit of a
thing going on much like hisoka's on and
off again fight relationship with
crawler and I swear in hisoka's mind
Hunter Hunter is less of a battle shoner
manga and more like showed your love
story but he's a high school student
constantly being seduced by his
classmates forming all sorts of complex
love triangles forcing hisoka to choose
but then they changed their minds
leading to heartbreak and heartache and
it's all just ah it's it's a lot of
personal drama during the same Arc
though we probably get the most
fascinating insight into hisoka's mind
which is when we see his mental Toy Box
a gathering of all of the people hisoka
would like to play with which does very
notably include karapika which you would
think is confirmation that hisoku is
interested but also not really in this
box you can also see characters like
Hanzo sir tots Menchie and buhara many
of which are retrospectively fairly
disappointing hunters and not at all the
solid Schwing generators that many of
the other characters present even though
Arya was still in the box so I don't
think the karapika's presence here means
much in his hoka's own words the more
toys the more fun so he's not very picky
with who he chooses to throw into the
box however he is very picky with his
favorite toys fun fact in this box the
2011 anime made him stake in the manga
just above Xeno zolda came behind the
text you can see Silva zoldik however
the 2011 anime confused Silva for machi
and so they gave him pink hair to be
fair silver and Machi do have very
similar outfits but the frizzy hair and
being next to Zeno should have been a
dead giveaway Machi is one character who
we don't actually see in this toy box
which is interesting because she's the
only one that hisoka has pursued a
traditionally romantic relationship with
so he may not consider her to be one of
his toys maybe he doesn't want to
actually fight Machi perhaps hisoka just
wants a nice dinner and some some good
old human intercourse I don't really
know what he wants and that's the entire
problem that we are trying to solve in
this video getting back on track it's
important to note that hisoka has not
encountered krapika since York New City
and thus he has no idea just how much
karapika has grown it's like planting a
tree in your backyard and then
forgetting that you have a backyard and
then one day you remember and you're
like damn that's that's a big tree given
kropica's increasing levels of
crawlerization I find it hard to believe
that hisoku would still show no interest
but but the problem is that hisoka is
still fixated on the original crawler I
mean I say problem this isn't a problem
for karapika in fact I'd say he's done
pretty well in this whole situation not
becoming a Target like gone did but it's
a problem from the perspective of hisoka
and I suppose it's also a problem for
crawler as a result but we can always
talk about what if and a hypothetical
matchup between krapika and hisoka is a
weirdly exciting thought I honestly
can't say with a huge degree of
confidence who I think would win unlike
most fights in Hunter Hunter this would
be a maybe balanced matchup and maybe it
needs its own video to explore that but
I Turn to You guys and after over 40 000
votes the clear opinion is that hisoka
would win potentially due to sheer
experience or the idea that at least one
of karapika's net abilities is dead in
the water against him whatever the case
the association has spoken do you want
to know the really weird thing the
karapika is one of the only characters
to have met hisoka and never experienced
bungee gum so karapika would be going
into this fight completely blind which
is a big issue because even when you
know it bungee gum is it's still a huge
pain to counter and keep track of but
thankfully for krapika that will never
be an issue from their very first
meeting hisoka has had very little
interest in krapika he was tested he
failed and while cropica has certainly
had quite the then glow up there is no
guarantee that he will ever be capable
of generating a swing